Netflix made a first reality show with
deep fakes falso Amore no one will know
if flirting or cheating on video is real
and at the end the couple who identifies
the largest number of fakes will receive
100 000 Euros can you detect whether
it's real now think again yep these are
deep fakes today they can be any kind of
image from crew drawings to portraits
indistinguishable from reality and
synthetic fraud utilizes Deep Fat
technology to a wider extent fake news
the pope wearing valenciaga or a
carefully crafted fake ID are all
examples of synthetic fraud we created a
game where you can guess if a person is
fake or not follow the link below to try
your best don't get scammed you're some
sub